circa due anni fa proprio in questi
giorni stavano iniziando a fare la mia
tesi di triennale in disegno industriale
all'idea di firenze
avevo appena passato l'estate in africa
in tanzania sull'isola di zanzibar e
passavo passavo le mie giornate in
cantiere insieme architetti ingegneri
per la progettazione di interni di
alcune abitazioni e resort è uno dei
problemi principali che aveva
quest'isola era l'accesso
all'elettricità e soprattutto l'accesso
all'acqua potabile e su una cosa e
locali non avevano problemi era
ovviamente avere della buona fresca
frutta tropicale ma erano bravi a
sconfiggere il caldo le abitazioni
tradizionali i suoi ri sono fatte di
fango e palme e spiccate e nonostante la
temperatura esterna sia oltre 40 gradi
la temperatura interna e molto fresca e
piacevole c'è quindi un'ottima
coibentazione il periodo di riflessione
che susseguì questo periodo africano fu
riguardo il nostro uso scriteriato di
elettricità di tutti gli elettrodi mesi
di tutto per sopperire al nostro shop
def jam quindi il nostro consumo dunque
sono appena torna in italia dopo questo
periodo iniziale con modera mitch
professori ingegneri per cercare di
capire come trasferire questo sistema a
questo momento abbiamo visto in africa
per creare un metodo di refrigerazione
che non utilizzasse energia elettrica e
e tutto si viene definito in evaporati
pooling è un principe in termodinamica
lo stesso principio per il quale quando
si ha la sudorazione corporea si abbassa
la temperatura interna quindi durante
l'evacuazione del liquido sia un
abbassamento della temperatura del
sistema
in questo princi in questo processo sono
importanti quattro variabili che sono la
ventilazione l'umidità relativa i
materiali utilizzati
è la superficie esterna per ognuna di
queste variabili sono state fatte delle
ricerche degli studi approfonditi e la
chiave di tutto è stato l'utilizzo dpcm
materiale a cambiamento di fase che sono
accumulatori di calore latente
la forma è stata progettata per creare
dei canali dove all'interno il fluido
aria passandovi aumenta la sua velocità
o per effetto venturi che il primo è un
paradosso idrodinamico me stesso
principio per il quale gli aerei volano
o le barche a vela vanno quasi
controvento e tutto questo per creare
un'auto ventilazione attorno all'oggetto
e per migliorarne quindi l'evaporazione
del liquido che alla base del principio
è stato realizzato un prototipo
funzionante insieme artigiani ceramisti
e delle aziende metallurgiche e frigyes
il mio progetto vuole rappresentare
l'energia naturale disponibile per tutti
un'energia salutare ed efficiente
una volta data quindi la tesi a
continuare a portare avanti alcuni studi
per ottimizzarne l'efficacia di questo
principio e e qualche mese dopo durante
un corso a trieste
venni a conoscenza di un certo global
accelera competition dove parlava di
dove la borsa di studio era andare tre
mesi al centro di ricerca nasa alla
simulare university in realtà non sapevo
neanche cosa fosse
quando poi iniziai andare a vedere di
cosa si trattasse i temi erano
nanotecnologie e biotecnologie
intelligenza artificiale e robotica
imprenditori a tutto questo tre mesi tre
mesi al centro di ricerca nasa con 80
studenti da tutto il mondo con diverso
background
la prima impressione primo pensiero fu
che figata
sembra quasi un ambiente
fantascientifico utopico e la
riflessione che seguì che venne dopo fu
anche chissà quante saranno le
probabilità che possa essere selezionata
ma preso da un raptus di follia ci
provai dovevo realizzare un video di 3
minuti un abstract e presentare in dieci
slide il mio progetto frigyes arriva
nei dieci finalisti e e dopo diversi
colloqui dove tra l'altro nei primi
colloqui mi dissero ok tra un'ora
tieniti pronta che ti chiamano dalla
california non accorgendomi chiaro in
mezzo della campagna mediana senza avere
internet quindi trovai una prima scuola
materna e feci il colloquio su delle
seggiole appunto con dei bambini intorno
e indietro
queste sono e slide vecchio ok era tempo
quindi di fare le fasi di fare le
valigie e andare in questo posto
fantascientifico iniziai quindi a
preparare queste erano le slide vecchie
ma ok a volte perché abbiano troppo
fuori tempo
questo era il cibo degli astronauti che
ci fecero iniziare a provare in realtà
non ve lo consiglio a davanti
l'obiettivo principale di questo di
questi tre mesi alla singolarità
divertiti a creare i progetti che
possano impattare da qui a 10 anni un
migliaio di persone in maniera positiva
ovvero un settimo della popolazione
globale e tutto grazie al attraverso le
global green challenge ovvero le grandi
sfide del che ci riguardano tutti e
riguardano la salute la con l'energia
l'ambiente il cibo nella sicurezza
l'istruzione e la povertà la chiave
manca una slide della racconto la chiave
è pensare in maniera esponenziale
ovvero pensare di vivere un app in una
pentola di pop corn dove negli ultimi
secondi avviene tutto qualche decina di
anni fa non ci saremmo mai immaginati
poter avere in tasca uno smartphone che
a un miliardo di potenza di calcolo in
più rispetto a il supercomputer che ci
mandò l'uomo sulla terra è necessario
che creatività innovazione e
imprenditorialità siano vadano tutte
insieme e si e sinergia contaminazione e
passione sono alla base ovvero designer
progettisti insieme
a scienziati e matematici filosofi
devono convivere e collaborare e
progettare insieme per arrivare a fare
progetti che possono veramente impattare
maniera positiva le persone uno degli
ambienti che più mafia mi ha affascinato
mi sono innamorata quest'estate si
chiama baio cruz un posto dove esperti
in genetica chiamano bambini persone di
tutte le età di tutte le professioni per
fare wars e progetti e abbiamo quindi
avuto la possibilità di giocare quindi
di creare colonie di batteri
fluorescenti di utilizzare un programma
che non è autocad man mano calda che
possiamo iniziare a progettare in
nanoscala è uno dei progetti nato da
questo ambiente multi disciplinare si
chiama ex lege no mix che ha l'intento
di trasformare per creare una
connessione tra la forma il significato
ovvero tra le informazioni che stanno
dietro al codice genetico e al loro
significato per avvicinare affascinare
il grande pubblico a questa grande
tematica che da qui a pochi anni sarà
molto importante è che ci farà scoprire
molte cose riguardo la nostra salute
questo è una parte una lettura parziale
del mio dna
e cosa possiamo scoprire riguarda il
passato il presente e il futuro della
nostra salute ovvero quali medicinali
possano farci bene farci male al nostro
corpo o quale malattie potremmo
sviluppare da qui a qualche anno quindi
quello che è necessario è trasformare
questa massa di informazioni che stanno
nel codice genetico in una sintesi
visiva e che quindi queste informazioni
possano uscire fuori dallo schermo dove
di entrare nel nel nostro quotidiano per
permettere alle persone di scoprire e di
raccontare la storia che sta dietro
queste forme che rappresenta il nostro
codice genetico
un esempio questo progettista designer
matti allenar francese ha trasformati e
codificate le informazioni relative a
dei paesi francia egitto
egli ha codificato
creando delle sculture quindi attraverso
l'altezza attraverso circonferenze si
possono e si possono capire le
informazioni di un paese tipologia di
habitat popolazione densità e il numero
degli abitanti
ovviamente il codice genetico ha un
grosso numero di informazioni e sono
anche molto complessi ma l'intento è
appunto quello di sintetizzarle
visivamente per creare un una
comprensione più intuitiva e visiva
vorrei terminare con una frase che peter
diamandis il fondatore della simula riti
nei versi di a citava molto spesso è the
only way you sempre dictation east verde
quindi costruiamo insieme il futuro
grazie